[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're unfamiliar this is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show real viewers try to find real
mistakes so far this is astounding many
challengers I think we've had over 100
people challenge us no winners so far
nobody has been able to catch us making
a mistake we don't make mistakes well
tonight a fan with the YouTube handle
velvet soldier
7:13 thinks he caught a mistake that
some name isn't it he says it happened
during a comedy sketch we recently did
about a man holding himself up by his
teeth let's see what velvet soldier 7:13
has to say hi Conan you recently did a
bit about a man setting a new world
record by holding himself up with a
string with just his mouth as a part of
the bit the man fell to the ground and
all that was left holding onto the clamp
with his mouth and his vertebral column
I don't know who taught you human
anatomy but those two things are not
connected whatsoever you wanted accuracy
his esophagus his stomach and so on and
so forth would have followed out instead
of his spine
next time you tried to pull a stunt like
that you better check your facts I got
you first of all get your finger out of
my face thing about those magazines you
have on the wall behind you will come in
handy when you cut out the letters to
make your ransom note okay anyway I'm
sorry
velvet soldier 713 but you need to get
your facts straight
the teeth are connected directly to the
spinal cord now to prove it we went to
great expense to hire a radiologist who
has a machine that can take an x-ray of
your body from the video you sent us
check it out Wow look at that right
there look
[Applause]
oh and something else we also took the
liberty of doing a cat scan on your
brain look what we found pal check it
out look what you got in there
I win
[Applause]
so the challenge still stands if you
think you spotted an error on our show
reporter team koco.com / ha ha I found
an error we will sort it out here on the
air let's see if you have what it takes
to make chutney
[Applause]